the economic ruptures caused by Russia's
war in Ukraine triggered a string of
Street protests in Moldova over the past
few months and recently led to the
collapse of the country's pro-european
government
another pro-western prime minister
Doreen retchen took over on Thursday
amid heightened security threats linked
to the war next door that's because the
former Soviet Republic is strategically
important to both Russia and Ukraine as
the war rages on here's why
Moldova is a small landlocked country
sandwiched between Romania in the west
and Ukraine to the east
it has a population smaller than that of
Chicago and the third lowest GDP per
capita of any European country it's
already struggling economy has taken a
hit since war broke out in Ukraine
inflation has soared amid moscow's
decision to squeeze natural gas supplies
prompting a wave of Street protests
and Russian attacks on the electrical
Grid in Ukraine have led to power cuts
for its tiny neighbor
while an influx of Ukrainian refugees
has strained moldova's Public Services
the situation comes at a time when the
country is cooperating closely with NATO
and seeking to join the European Union
it is on a real pro-reform
anti-corruption and European past this
has worsened moldova's relations with
Russia some pro-western politicians in
Moldova and Ukraine have accused the
Kremlin of planning a coup to
destabilize the country
is
on February 9th Ukraine's president said
he had shared intelligence of his
moldovan counterpart about an alleged
Russian scheme to topple her country's
democratic system of government
a day later moldova's pro-western
government collapsed citing the economic
challenges brought on by the war
and not long after that the country's
president said she had confirmed details
of zelenski's statement and that
Russia's plan included attacks on
government buildings and taking hostages
Russia dismissed the allegations as
unfounded saying Ukraine was attempting
to draw Moldova into a confrontation of
Moscow
the US said it hadn't been able to
independently confirm the alleged coup
plot
what I'll say about that is
deeply concerning reports certainly
not outside the bounds of Russian
Behavior the destabilized Moldova is in
Russia's interest according to one
analyst and could pose a security threat
to Western Ukraine
Russia has troops stationed in the
Breakaway region of transnistria the
thin strip of land on moldova's eastern
border with Ukraine is run by
pro-russian separatists
if Ukraine had to allocate resources to
counter that threat it could diminish
the chances of success in the southeast
of the country the analysts said
these factors raise fears that the war
could spill out Beyond Ukraine's borders
and highlight their important role
Moldova might play for both sides in the
coming months